بتصميم قوي وموقف ثابت ينظر مارك الى كل
ما يجري في دانيتك فاعوام التصعيد مع
اوكرانيا تركت بصماتها على المنطقه
وسكانها ولا تزال هو عامل منجم سابق يتطلع
حاليا الى المستقبل مستقبل ستكون
الانتخابات الاولى في تاريخ المنطقه بعد
ضمها الى روسيا بوابه له حسب تعبيره
حصلت مؤخرا على الجوازير الروسي وهذا امر
مهم بالنسبه الي فانا روسي القوميه والان
عندما اصبحنا جزءا من روسيا بتنا نستطيع
تحديد مستقبلنا بانفسنا ولذلك وبالطبع
ساشارك في الانتخابات تمر دانيس
كورونسكون بعد ضمها الى روسيا بمرحله
انتقاليه تتطلب من السلطات الروسيه فعل
الكثير لادماجها وتكاملها مع باقي الاراضي
الروسيه وهذه الانتخابات يرى كثيرون هنا
انها ستتوج عمليه الانضمام ق ودستوريا
[موسيقى]
الاستفتاء على الانضمام الى روسيا كان
حدثا تاريخيا اما هذه الانتخابات فهي
العنصر الاساسي الضروري لبناء هيكل السلطه
الدستوريه التي لا بد لها ان تكون على
اراضينا
انتخابات استثنائيه تجرى في ظل تصعيد
عسكري وقصف متواصل ولذلك بدات عمليه
التصويت على مراحله تستبق ايام الانتخاب
الرسميه لدواعي امنيه فنظمت رحلات مراكز
الاقتراع الى الاماكن الخطره والنائيه
ليتمكن الجميع من التصويت
تاتون الى مثل هذه الاماكن لجمع اصوات
المواطنين لماذا تقومون بذلك
الاقتراع نحو 30 شخصا صوتهن هذا الصباح
رغم المخاطر ياملون ان يساعدهم ذلك في
تخطي كل الصعوبات
اعداد كبيره من السكان المحليين غادرت
المنطقه فقد غادر قرابه النصف وفقا
لتقديرات غير رسميه جلهم الى روسيا ولذلك
افتتح نحو 300
مركز اقتراع في احدى وثمانين منطقه روسيه
كي يتمكن اولئك من التصويت كثيرون يشككون
في مصداقيه وشرعيه هذا الاختراع الذي يجري
في ظل ظروف امنيه وعسكريه صعبه الا ان
السلطات الروسيه تؤكد اتخاذها كل
الاجراءات الضروريه لضمان شرعيه هذه
الانتخابات التي توصف هنا بالتاريخيه
رانيا ريدي الجزيره دانياسكو